que seja muito bem-vindos
7 estamos em tempos de Halloween eu
comprei aqui máscaras novas
e hoje eu vou aproveitar que tem várias
amigas YouTubers aqui em casa então eu
vou aproveitar para assustar os pessoal
já deixem o nosso like Espero que gostem
do vídeo
[Música]
já avisei que vai dar merda isso
[Aplausos]
[Música]
agora eu vou citar
[Aplausos]
mano como assim meu tô só aqui jogar um
Fifa tranquilo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu não consigo arrancar a mágica Alguém
me ajuda eu não conseguia
[Música]
[Risadas]
agora tu vais-me ajudar a assustar
os outros vou pensar que já não há mais
sujos
Ok vamos ver se isto funciona deixem
like aí
eu tô tripédia
eu sou viciado mesmo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bom Vampiro
7 não se esqueçam também de assistir
este vídeo está muito engraçado pessoal
e é isso Espero que gostem fiquem bem
até a próxima